you're welcome to this video playing
Grand Master month ago from Thailand and
yeah I know what is playing is no friend
of mine yeah
okay yeah I don't really have a concrete
idea here what to do let's go to the the
double Fugit oh oh he's playing he's
playing it entirely different like it
Kings Indian attack
yeah this is always on a playable option
for white not a bad opening fairly
fairly solid so proud to play maybe here
97 looks are also good but my idea yes
5d hive if he allows me to do that yeah
but isn't isn't this quite quite
unambitious to lead to mass exchanges
yeah there's not much not much going on
here this kind of structures some quite
common in this Kings Indian attack
setups where he had upon I've changed
and did so it's really not much not much
happening what I'm trying to do is I try
to maneuver my night to deform this is a
good idea he's trying to harass my king
of it but nite nite b4 c64 this a really
good positional idea oops here we go
yeah he's right in the hitch he went
right into the to the service fork and
see three years and not a move that
white wants to play maybe you need to
okay now my ideas e 6 root d5 rope d8
putting pressure on the depot and then
try to play quickly not spend a jcm
tending 95 so that I can really attack
the depot
okay so there's no technical trick here
okay ready to maybe get b5 into the edge
of the mixer
night III look B 395 is a pretty cheap
trick but in with an effective trick
should pay attention yes that don't
really mind to to get get this off I
mean it's not like it's helping me but
it's also not another problem
who the take d3 is taking c5
yeah I'm in taking two pawns him I
probably was only one of them 24 nice
and 24 i don't like somebody pensive
some tags
yep don't know was there no way to takes
rook takes Queen f3 is a possibility
this rock t fall down
I see also has some just just King age
too
look be 4i can cook teeth I can also
play with the aid I can take yeah this
is Sir this is of course possible one
look do you wonders look BA that I made
myself so I'm going to threaten that you
I forgot about that okay
no the rook
intending rooty one
Queen h1z1 major the threat
not really this is working
hmm
thread twinsies one
check ah what Nick
now probably it's a drawer with Rob g6
check check check check
maybe that isn't the draw let's check
time warning check check check check
check check check white resins poor
young man should have been a draw i
guess he tried absolutely everything to
to to to get in my king but i think it's
just to draw him why probably must play
some some some quieting with him this is
some knobs not really really on Queen a
seven years old so it's even better yeah
this is better of course yeah just queen
air seven here's your threatening Queen
g1 and there's no counter play at all
and some the zone this seems to be
better flat like but not winning your PG
two drawers here the computers of course
playing the sound like a perfectly check
check what's here isn't thing I know he
can give more checks i can run to the
queenside probably a it isn't a drawer
simply check canvas was most easier than
butts ok didn't have any time so a good
fighting game but it should have ended
in the draw ok thanks for watching